[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
definitely setting the stage for
something
that is sure to be contentious the
prosecution star witness takes the stand
in the federal trial of michael avenatti
plus who president biden intends to
nominate as the next supreme court
justice that person will be the first
black woman ever nominated to united
states supreme court
and prince andrew wants a trial by jury
amid sexual abuse allegations from an
epstein survivor but first ladies and
gentlemen that's my understanding you've
reached the verdict is that correct
a verdict is handed down in the trial of
wisconsin versus theodore edgecombe law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian brockmeyer along with terry
austin after just two hours of two and a
half hours of deliberation a wisconsin
jury reaches a verdict in the murder
trial of theodore edgecombe
we the jury find the defendant theodore
edgecombe
guilty of first degree reckless homicide
a lesser included offense of count one
of the information
based on that the jury was requested and
asked to answer a second question
did the defendant commit the offense of
first-degree reckless homicide while
using a dangerous weapon
answer yes
it's signed today by the four person
who's juror number four
based on that verdict everybody i'm
gonna pull the jury all right i've
pulled the jury the jury has confirmed
their verdict of guilty of first degree
reckless homicide a lesser included
offense of count one of the information
edgecombe now faces up to 60 years in
prison he was found guilty of
first-degree reckless homicide the
lesser offense to first-degree
intentional homicide charges that
conviction carries a mandatory life
sentence of in prison in wisconsin
edgecombe's conviction stems from the
september 2020 death of jason clearman a
milwaukee immigration attorney edgecombe
says he was riding his bike when
clearman and his wife swiped him with
their car
video footage shows edgecombe punching
clearman through the open passenger side
window after that the car follows
edgecomb security footage shows clearman
eventually get out of the car and
confront the defendant that's when
edgecombe shot him he was arrested six
months later in kentucky while edgecombe
always maintained self-defense he
testified quote the gun just went off he
also pled guilty to felony and
misdemeanor bail jumping in connection
to the case sentencing for edgecomb is
set for april 8.
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin matthew what's your reaction to
the speed in which the jury dropped the
first two counts and went straight to
reckless homicide
yeah it was quick it was two and a half
hours and uh really uh brian i i think
this was a compromise verdict i think
they looked at both of these individuals
as not
not having clean hands um they they uh
the victim followed him um he confronted
him uh the defendant turned around shot
him in the face you know i think that
they believe that there was some
provocation but there wasn't
self-defense primarily because the
defendant himself did not say it was
self defense he said it was an
accidental shooting uh so i i believe it
was a compromise based on the fact that
both the defendant and the victim here
uh did not have clean hands in the way
this whole
thing turned out yeah no clean hands
that's definitely a good way to put it
terry the jury settled for first degree
reckless homicide do you think defense
counsel should have explained the
differences between the charges to the
jury a little better
absolutely he should have done two
things explain the charges and also
explain that self-defense so he should
have said that the defendant intended to
defend himself but he didn't intend to
kill the victim so that would explain
the discrepancy in that testimony and he
should have explained what homicide by
negligent handling of a dangerous weapon
is because that is the lace charge that
he was charged with and that's 10 years
versus the 60 years he's going to get
for that first degree reckless homicide
so if he explained that maybe he'd get
some less time there yeah seemed like
the jury was receptive to some arguments
but not to all we'll see how that plays
out as sentencing comes up soon
on to news out of idaho for the latest
development on the so-called doomsday
duo on thursday judge stephen boyce
ruled the defense can have more time to
file a motion to dismiss the case chad
dabell and his wife lori valo daybel
face a 2023 trial for the murders of her
children tyler ryan and j.j valo along
with the murder of tammy dabel chad's
first wife months after the children
were reported missing their bodies were
found on chad dabal's property the pair
became known as the doomsday duo because
of their belief that the end of time was
near on thursday chad davil did not
appear virtually in the hearing but was
represented by attorney john pryor pryor
argued a lengthy grand jury transcript
set him back on drafting future emotions
while the prosecution argued multiple
extensions have already been granted
this is five days of grand jury
testimony
the standard judge is excusable neglect
but there hasn't been any neglect here
but there has been i've been diligent in
going through all of this information
reviewing all of this and quite frankly
judge
the the magnitude of the work
um
is going to require that i'll need some
additional time to do that the state in
this case did not object to mr pryor's
first two motions
uh as as has already been stated the
grand jury transcript was not prepared
that's certainly good cause for an
extension of time
uh however the court would further at
the state would further note
uh that uh
there are those timelines do exist and
failure to exercise those rights in a
timely manner does uh constitute a
waiver of such right
and as you've indicated you do now have
uh come
the completed transcripts and you've
reviewed those
so i don't know that this needs to get
extended
any longer than possible because i think
the state
is correct that it's entitled to know
the answer to this question is preparing
for trial which it's already starting to
do
so i will grant the motion
a hearing for a motion to dismiss the
case is set for march 18th
in florida a convicted killer will spend
the rest of her life behind bars for the
murder of her former co-worker in
december a jury found kimberly kessler
guilty of first-degree murder in the
death of jolene cummings a 34-year-old
mother of three who disappeared in 2018.
the two worked together at a hair salon
in cummings body has never been found
jurors also convicted her on theft
charges for dumping cummings vehicle the
night of her disappearance kessler had a
reputation for loud outburst when she
was wheeled into the courtroom for trial
yelling things about her former attorney
being related to the victim which wasn't
the case so kessler watched the court
proceedings from a separate room there
was also a debate over her ability to
stand trial she was originally deemed
incompetent after her arrest in 2019.
she was sentenced thursday to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
still ahead on law and crime daily after
27 years on the supreme court justice
stephen breyer is set to retire who
president joe biden says may be
appointed next
but first prince andrew says he wants a
trial by jury in the virginia jew phrase
sexual assault lawsuit all that and more
still ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back an update now out of texas
an armed and dangerous fugitive is now
in custody after investigators say he
shot and killed an officer last weekend
oscar rosales is charged with capital
murder in the death of corporal charles
galloway investigators say rosales shot
galloway during a traffic stop sunday
morning houston's police chief says
video shows rosales get out of his car
with an assault type weapon and opened
fire on galloway while the deputy was
still sitting in his patrol vehicle
rosales was on the run for days until he
was found at a hotel in mexico nearly
600 miles west of houston rosales's wife
and brother-in-law are charged with
tampering with evidence after they were
found cleaning the truck investigators
say he was driving at the time of the
shooting rosalis arrest comes amid a
string of officer-involved shootings
over the last week including two new
york city police officers who were
killed in the line of duty while
answering a domestic violence call also
a wisconsin sheriff's deputy was shot
and killed on wednesday morning the
suspect was later found dead by suicide
and prince andrew is formally denying
any claims that convicted sex offender
jeffrey epstein trafficked girls to him
he's now demanding a jury trial in the
virginia duffray sexual abuse lawsuit
jeffrey has alleged for years that
epstein and his former companion gillane
maxwell forced her to have sex with
their friends including prince andrew
two decades ago when she was underage in
the filing submitted on wednesday the
prince did admit to spending time with
epstein and maxwell on several occasions
over the last 22 years all this comes
just two weeks after a judge denied
prince andrew's request to dismiss
duprey's lawsuit and after queen
elizabeth stripped prince andrew of his
royal titles earlier this month maxo was
convicted in december of several sex
crimes including sex trafficking she is
set to be sentenced in june her
co-conspirator and former boyfriend
epstein was charged with similar crimes
but he was found dead in his jail cell
before he went to trial
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin to discuss prince andrew's
response to trafficking allegations
terry prince andrew continues to deny
drew frey's claims but now he says that
if any sexual activity did occur it was
consensual can he have it both ways
i don't think that works he has a legal
right to claim in the alternative but on
the one hand you are claiming you didn't
have sex but if you did it was
consensual it doesn't look good to the
jury it was either one or the other
these types of alternate arguments work
best if the underlying facts are similar
so for instance a malicious assault
versus whether or not it was a reckless
assault the underlying facts are the
same but actually you can argue the
alternative so i think it doesn't work
here yeah especially in front of a jury
matthew along with asserting 11
affirmative defenses prince andrew is
demanding a jury trial why do you think
he wants that over a bench trial
well you know as we know um brian
this is an answer to a complaint the
complaint was filed the lawsuit was
filed uh prince andrew tried to have
that dismissed without filing a response
that was uh denied so now he has to
follow a formal response so so a lot of
these are boilerplate answers you know i
don't have enough information to form a
uh
an opinion or a decision as to the
truth or falsity of the environment
those sorts of things
and it's customary at this point
certainly to ask for a jury trial i
think ultimately they're going to want a
jury trial they're not going to want to
go in front of a judge with this kind of
uh evidence and these kind of statements
they're going to want to go in front of
you know a jury of his peers if you can
find peers for a prince
but a jury of his peers and hope that
they can convince them that the
prosecution can't prove their case
beyond a reasonable doubt all right
we'll see how it plays out as we're just
in the beginning phases of this coming
up on law and crime daily the government
star witness takes a stand in the
federal trial of michael avenatti plus
president joe biden is doubling down on
a campaign promise who could be
appointed next to the supreme court of
the united states
[Music]
welcome back president joe biden
promised to nominate the first black
woman to the supreme court just one day
after justice stephen breyer announced
his plans to retire in a press
conference on thursday president bayern
reinforced a long-time campaign promise
that his first supreme court nomination
would be a black woman he said it was
quote long overdue that a black one be
appointed to the highest court he also
commended justice breyer on his 28 years
of service as a scotus justice the 83
year old justice breyer is the oldest
supreme court justice and notably he is
one of three remaining liberal justices
president biden said the future
appointee would embody important
characteristics like integrity
i was proud and grateful to be there at
the start of this distinguished career
in the supreme court
and i'm very proud to be here today
on his announcement of his retirement
choosing someone to sit in the supreme
court
i believe is one of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has
our process is going to be rigorous
i will select the nominee
worthy of justice briar's legacy of
excellence and decency
while i've been studying candidates
backgrounds and writings
i've made no decision except one
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
i made that commitment during the
campaign for president and i will keep
that commitment
president biden says he intends to
announce his decision by the end of
february but he has not yet made a
decision right now the court is split
six to three between conservative and
liberal justices
criminal defense attorney matthew
mangino and co-host terry austin join us
to discuss the scotus future
terry biden has promised to select a
black woman as the next supreme court
justice why do you think this is so
important to him
you know it's important to him because
he understands that black women are
underrepresented in leadership positions
and he said he wants to change those
dynamics and it's very important for him
to do so he made a presidential promise
and he's going to keep that and it's
interesting james clyburn actually
reminded him to mention that during the
campaign so he wants to keep that
promise now matthew judge katanji
brown-jackson is believed to be on the
short list of appointees and if selected
she would be the first former public
defender how could that affect scotus
well i think it would be important to
have a former public defender be a part
of the court uh to get that perspective
of criminal defense particularly
indigent criminal defense uh when we
think of um you know judge jackson
she's on the dc circuit which which is
kind of a prerequisite to being on the
supreme court she would be the fourth
member of the court who's from the dc
circuit uh she was a briar uh um clerk
so she fits the profile and i think she
would be
an excellent member of the united states
supreme court all right we'll see how
that process goes
so much grooming for this and of course
we will follow it as it continues down
the process of a new supreme court
justice when we come back the federal
trial of disgrace attorney michael
avenatti stormy daniels takes the stand
as a prosecution star witness that's
still ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily we head
to minnesota for day four in the federal
trial of three former minneapolis police
officers charged in the death of george
floyd on the stand thursday a longtime
academy instructor
now inspector katie blackwell told
jurors about the duty officers have to
intervene if someone is using
unnecessary force on a suspect blackwell
is the first minnesota officer to
testify in the case she testified about
the department's official policy
mandating officers prioritize sanctity
of life in any situation prosecutors say
three former officers jay alexander king
thomas lane and two tao deprive floyd of
his constitutional rights by not
intervening when derek shovin held him
down murdering him as of now lane is
expected to testify in the case he is
the only defendant not charged with
failure to intervene presumably because
he asked chauvin multiple times to
change floyd's position cameras are not
allowed inside the federal courtroom
throughout the trial the three officers
will also have a state trial that is
scheduled for june
also in federal court the prosecution
star witness takes the stand in the
trial of disgrace attorney michael
avenatti avenatti's former client and
the star witness in the case stormy
daniels testified on thursday
daniels whose real name is stephanie
clifford alleges avenatti stole 300
thousand dollars out of an advance for
her memoir prosecutors say avenatti
forged her signature and later lied to
her about where the money was going an
indictment says he used the money to pay
law firm employees and for personal
expenses like making a luxury car
payment avenatti rose to fame while
representing daniels a one-time adult
film actress who accused former
president donald trump of providing her
with hush money payments to quiet news
of their affair on thursday avenatti
began cross-examination of daniels is
expected to continue on friday
law and crime network's adam claffeld
was at the courthouse thursday he tells
us the judge already appears to be
frustrated with avenatti
well it was a dramatic day on the stand
right before
the proceedings even began today you had
michael avenatti informing the judge
that he intended to cross-examine stormy
daniels for six hours and the judge's
response uh was we'll see about those
six hours so right off the bat we
set the stage for this combative
cross-examination but today was about
direct examination we saw the beginning
of his cross-examination today with
stormy daniels
we uh we
there weren't too many surprises there
we knew going in that he was going to
try to discredit her because of her
appearance in this tv series spooky
babes
and her belief in the paranormal
this was something that was signaled
when he was represented by lawyers
but he's questioning her about her
beliefs in the paranormal
asked her whether she
has said that she has spoken to and seen
dead people she said yes
so no surprises there
matthew avenatti's argument seems to
suggest this is a contract dispute blown
out of proportion does he have some kind
of an advantage representing himself
because he knows the contract and what
was said
well i don't know that it's ever an
advantage to represent yourself i mean
we've heard over and over uh about the
comments of abraham lincoln and others
uh but
you know you don't switch horses
midstream uh this is going to be a very
difficult process already as we've heard
uh there's some um animosity between him
and the judge and how he's going to
direct his cross-examination uh you know
to suggest that this is a contractual
dispute certainly there was a contract
uh but
um
he forged a letter allegedly uh to
divert money that was supposed to go to
stormy daniels into his own account uh
that that gets beyond contract disputes
now we're talking about criminal
activity and that's why we're here uh in
in this case right now uh so
i don't think he's going to impress the
jury uh with his lawyering on his own
behalf
and
i think he had a long road to ho here
terry stormy daniels testified in court
and claimed that avenatti would
represent her for a hundred dollars plus
a share of any money awarded as a result
of the lawsuit against trump does that
sound right
it doesn't sound right brian who would
represent anyone for a hundred dollars
but apparently avenatti said that he
would raise money in a defense fund but
even that doesn't sound right to me
because he could be ethically influenced
there if he wanted to raise more money
so i don't think it makes sense we'll
see how it plays out well thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you